it has long been the mission of the scp
foundation to secure and contain any
anomalies they encounter all to protect
the safety of the human race sometimes
containing an scp is a trivial task as
simple as guarding a room or keeping an
eye on an artifact with strange but
mostly harmless properties other times
though anomalies require a considerable
number of the foundation's personnel and
resources to keep them under control
this latter category commonly includes
some of the most dangerous creatures and
entities that the scp foundation keeps
under lock and key however while it
might be only in very rare cases every
so often an scp comes along with its
very own built-in method of containment
this can often be the result of someone
encountering an anomaly and discovering
the perfect way of imprisoning it before
the scp foundation comes along and
steals all the credit undoubtedly this
makes the job of securing an anomaly all
the easier for the foundation's staff
after all someone else has already done
the hard part of the job for them or
rather it would make things easier if
only the foundation's own researchers
chose not to interfere and could leave a
deadly threat kept safely in its box
without trying to find out what makes it
tick
scp-5001 is in some ways a reminder that
some things are best left alone but it
is also a grave warning not to tamper
with that which you do not understand
both of these lessons would soon be
imparted on the scp foundation buried 60
kilometers below the ground in northern
russia is
scp-5001 a 53-kilometer wide structure
it is an enormous biomechanical machine
but to the untrained eye there is
nothing anomalous about the object and
according to the foundation's findings
this is indeed the case there is nothing
inherently anomalous about the structure
itself but there are a number of
characteristics that seem to suggest it
is in some way connected to anomalous
phenomena for one there is the sheer
scale of the structure and then there's
the records that were uncovered about
scp-5001
which appeared to have been monitoring
and tracking its status perhaps whoever
constructed it or discovered it kept a
record as they observed the structure
nothing too out of the ordinary about
that but what's strange
is that these date back to 11 000 bc and
yet we're somehow made with modern
systems of measurement and other weirder
documents have been recovered from
inside of scp-5001
records written in languages from all
over the world and even some in
languages lost to time among them are
papers in phoenician ancient hebrew both
ancient and modern greek latin
anglo-saxon along with modern russian
english and mandarin some of these
documents are even written in languages
that the scp foundation's top
researchers are yet to properly identify
the explanation for all this would seem
obvious wouldn't it writing in both
ancient and contemporary languages
records that date all the way back to
the last of the prehistoric era it all
seems to point in a certain direction
somehow
scp-5001 has a link to time travel
perhaps it was even a hub for a group of
time travelers right wrong the
foundation already thought that this
might be the case and checked for any
signs of temporal anomalies and yet they
found nothing no evidence to suggest
that there had ever been any time travel
near or using as cp 5001 there were no
devices on site that could affect time
and no traces of any residue or fallout
from a temporal occurrence so what
exactly does this thing even do
well we're afraid to say the foundation
researchers have been stumped on the
answer to that question too and they are
not the only ones either way back in the
50s the gru's division p also had an
interest in scp-5000
for anyone who isn't already acquainted
with them they are one of the scp
foundation's numerous groups of interest
a list of organizations corporations and
agencies from around the world who have
also had dealings with anomalies in the
case of grup they were originally a
division of the russian army during the
cold war the specialty of gru division p
was the acquisition of anomalous objects
and entities in other words they were
the soviet union's very own scp
foundation in 1953 gru division p was
alerted to abnormal seismic activity in
a narrow region of northern russia a
team was immediately sent in to
investigate and began attempting to take
seismic measurements of the area in
question during their various
experiments and tests gru division p
realized a discrepancy in their readings
again and again they checked and double
checked their results only to discover
that this reading wasn't the result of
faulty equipment or even human error
there was something big nearby what they
hadn't yet realized was around 30
kilometers away deep underground was
scp-5001
immediately gru division p began
drilling towards the location of
scp-5001
but for years found that they were
unable to breach the exterior of the
structure defeated the project was
abandoned in 1955
however soviet leader first secretary
khrushchev seemed to have a vested
interest in gaining access to scp-5001
as a result he privately funded the gru
division p operation allowing them to
continue their work in secret for a
number of years from 1959 until
khrushchev was disposed in 1964.
of course this was all during the height
of the cold war but by the late 1960s
international relations between the
soviet union and the united states of
america were starting to ease thanks to
the relaxing tensions a contract was
introduced allowing the two nations
secret organizations to work together on
a number of operations involving
potentially dangerous anomalies this
meant that the scp foundation was
finally able to step in and contribute
to the gru division ps project
concerning
scp-5001 their first task actually
getting inside the subterranean
structure naturally given how
well-versed the foundation is in dealing
with anomalies they had ideas for how to
crack this nut by acquiring anomalous
technology from the global occult
coalition another group of interest as
well as experimental designs created by
one dr elijah rachma the scp foundation
were finally able to breach the
structure in 1971 from then until the
dissolution of the soviet union in 1991
the scp foundation and gru division p
worked together to conduct a number of
studies into the origin and purpose of
scp-5001
both organizations were curious as to
the technology the structure possessed
and attempts were even made to recreate
some of the devices found within among
this advanced technology were
ontological stabilizers also known as
scranton reality anchors which are
located around
scp-5001's inner chamber these were
designed to directly alter the amount of
humes in a given area what's a hume well
to keep it simple a hume is a measure of
the reality around us if it helps
imagine reality as a pile of sand now
imagine that you remove a single grain
of sand from the pile congratulations
you just removed one hume from this
reality taking one away doesn't really
do much but start grabbing handfuls and
the pile gets smaller scattered less a
pile and more a light dusting of sand
reality works the same way take too much
away and it starts to lose whatever it
was before being able to alter the
amount of humes in an area meant that
these ontological stabilizers could
alter the strength of reality itself
even nullify the reality bending
properties of some anomalies in theory
and scp with the power to influence
reality could be contained using this
technology the effects of their
abilities reduce significantly although
not negated entirely another noteworthy
piece of technology uncovered was
codenamed omega omega was discovered in
an unmarked room on a computer terminal
that was connected to every area of
scp-5001 by dozens of cables the
software itself was an artificial
intelligence construct a computerized
consciousness that seemed to serve the
purpose of controlling the various
systems within
scp-5001 the omega seemed to work by
providing an answer whenever someone
used a keyboard to input a question the
artificial intelligence of omega
appeared able to hold a conversation but
would refuse to give any insight into
when the scp-5001 structure was built or
what its purpose was despite neither
group knowing what
scp-5001's function was an agreement
between the scp foundation and gru
division p was formed both organizations
shared the belief that omega the
ontological stabilizers as well as the
other anomalous technologies could never
under any circumstances be allowed to
fall into the wrong hands they had a
pack to keep the knowledge of
scp-5001 and these devices strictly
between themselves however this
agreement was sadly not to last in the
early 90s gru division p liquidated its
assets and disbanded a number of the
russian division's highest ranking
officers stole the anomalous technology
that the organization had in its
possession which they then sold to
marshall carter and dark limited m c and
d ltd are yet another of the scp
foundation's groups of interest
according to foundation intelligence
marshall carter and dark limited is a
london-based club that has caused
numerous problems for the foundation
over the years they have ties to wealthy
figures across the globe and cater to
the super rich clientele by providing
them with the most exclusive expensive
and rare experiences available how do
they do this by gathering the anomalous
items and auctioning them off to the
highest bidders a number of gru division
p operatives also joined up with the
chaos insurgency this is a group of
interests that consists of personnel who
previously worked for the foundation but
have since broken away to pursue their
own rogue agenda much like a number of
other groups of interest the insurgency
uses anomalies and scps for their own
benefit as well as dabbling in a bit of
arms dealing and the selling of highly
classified intelligence hey it's good to
have a diverse portfolio despite former
members of gru division p seeking
alternative employment with some less
than reputable groups the scp foundation
still managed to keep the existence and
location of
scp-5001 a closely guarded secret
however even with the structure fully
under their control their leading
researchers were still baffled as to
what exactly the purpose of the
underground structure was or rather that
was the case on december 30 2019 an
explosion erupted in the northeast
sector of scp-5001
the cause of the explosion was unknown
but the damage caused a tremendous and
almost catastrophic loss of power
whether the explosion had been triggered
by one of the many groups of interest
like the former gru division p or just a
machinery malfunction it almost caused
the total destruction of scp-5001
what would be so bad about that well
remember earlier when we said that every
so often an scp comes along with its
very own built-in method of containment
you see it wasn't the structure or
technology of
scp-5001 that the foundation should have
been worried about it was the thing
inside of scp-5001
just as some foundation researchers had
long theorized
scp-5001 was a cage a containment unit
for its own anomalous objects within
something powerful enough to alter
reality right down to the humes hence
the need for ontological stabilizers to
dampen its power and omega to keep the
place running this entity known either
as scp-5001
or the devourer was being held inside
scp-5001
and when the structure was damaged it
was almost freed while there was no data
on
scp-5001's computer system about this
being's appearance or the extent of its
anomalous powers whoever created
scp-5001 went to considerable effort to
keep the devourer contained viewing it
as a threat to all of reality and all
that effort was almost undone when the
structure was damaged by the explosion
fortunately the scp foundation was able
to re-establish containment of
scp-5001-a
though at the cost of a tremendous
amount of lives when personnel were
finally permitted to re-enter scp-5001
a number of the structure's core systems
had been damaged but it was still able
to perform its primary function and keep
the devourer safely contained within as
personnel entered the structure a
message appeared through the omega
computer system that read hello my
children although you have grown
immensely since your earliest days you
have much room to grow your species
intellect is merely a bud with so much
potential your weapons are powerful your
medicine is supreme your engineering is
beautiful with proper guidance and care
you are sure to reach an elevated state
of being and transcend your bodies for
something more whole and perfect that is
why it pains me so dearly to request
that you leave this place immediately
your studying and probing have almost
resulted in the end of all i have worked
towards to keep you alive if you comply
i guarantee that the devourer will never
escape and your species will be free to
pursue the enlightenment of technology
for all eternity let this be my final
gift to you directly from the center of
my broken heart okay back up broken
heart
interesting where have we heard
something like that before we'd hate to
jump to any conclusions but when one
hears about a being of great power
related to large and mysterious machines
and that word again
broken all the groups of interest that
seemed to be tied into
scp-5001 and we'd neglected to mention
perhaps the most important of all the
church of the broken god this religious
organization that reveres industry and
technology over the impurity of flesh
has been united in a singular purpose
rebuilding their deity the broken god
meccan whose body was split apart in an
attempt to preserve the future of
mankind perhaps the heart of this great
and ancient machine this devourer is
actually the heart of something else
entirely though of course there's only
so much we can speculate knowledge after
all can sometimes be like a flame it can
light your way but if you get too close
you will inevitably be burned if ever
you're in doubt ask the people devoured
and assimilated by the heart of meccan
the last time it was freed by the church
if ever the heart gets out again
you'll certainly be with them
the scp foundation has come so far their
technology their knowledge their vast
resources all allow them to contain some
of the most powerful forces mankind has
ever seen and even some we haven't but
as
scp-5001 shows there is still much that
even the brightest researchers at the
foundation don't yet understand and
their drive to poke and prod at the
unknown nearly led to the end of reality
as we know it perhaps one day we'll be
able to fully understand just what the
devourer is and the ways that scp-5001
work to protect us from it but we're not
there yet and there's no guarantee that
we ever will be while the pursuit of
knowledge is always an admirable one
when it comes to
scp-5001 maybe the foundation should
have left well enough alone now go check
out
scp-5545 mysterious tunnels in
antarctica abnormality and
scp-1461 house of the worm for more
mysterious underground structures from
the files of the scp
foundation you